Oh Jackie no pants you must be Peter  Rabbit right Oh generous honest pure  graceful creatures our natural rabbit to  pay stubs of people Jay what that would  never have worked no pants you must be  Peter Rabbit that's right wait did you  try to eat me show me your teeth do like  a  [Music]  [Music]  hello  [Music]  new neighbor I'll explain it to him  we'll share our land around here hello  I'm Bea these gates are incredibly  sturdy I just need to keep the wildlife  out where they belong you're joking  right yes they're angels this is their  place okay so he's tricked up there's  only one way out of this he's gotta go  so classic I have a vermin problem an  electric pencil paper mail no mrs.  tiggy-winkle stop  look away we can't give up it's our old  easy  your mind ribbit  [Applause]  [Music]  let's go along it went to boys getting  along  nothing could make me happier I got us  into this I'm gonna fix it  [Music]  [Music]  you